[Musik]
zweieinhalb monate brutalster angriffe
der russischen armee gegen die ukraine
liegen hinter uns die kriegsziele sind
nicht erreicht jetzt kommt die
atomwaffen drohung bei mir ist claudia
mayor sie beschäftigen sich mit
militärischer strategie stehen wir vor
einem atomkrieg also die russischen
drohungen die wir zur letzter zeit viel
gehört haben sind extrem
verantwortungslos und sie sind extrem
beunruhigend gleichzeitig sollten wir
aber auch nicht in panik verfallen denn
allein schon die drohung mit der bombe
ist ein teil der russischen ist eine
russische waffe gegen uns der faktor und
wenn wir jetzt in panik verfallen
erreicht russland genau das was es
möchte nämlich uns zu verunsichern
deshalb jahr wir müssen das sehr ernst
nehmen aber wir sollten nicht in panik
verfallen wir haben möglicherweise ja
das wurde immer mal wieder als thema
gespielt eine taktische nuklearwaffen
über der ostsee die gezündet wird die
dann angst verbreitet
können sich so etwas vorstellen ist das
realistisch wir müssen zwei sachen
unterscheiden und es ist wichtig dass
auseinanderzunehmen ich glaube das eine
ist zu überlegen was wir russland mit
diesen drohungen die wir jetzt vor dem
krieg und seit beginn des krieges immer
wieder hatten was für russland damit
erreichen und die andere frage ist wie
kann man diese drohungen einordnen wenn
ich mit dem ersten anfang was für
russland damit erreichen dass hat sowohl
mit den strategischen waffen das sind
die liebes in die usa erreichen können
als auch mit den taktischen das sind
eher so die man
auch in dem konflikt einsetzen könnte
gedroht das heißt was ist das ziel
hinter diesen drohungen und das eine ist
einmal das signal an die westlichen
staaten zu sagen haltet euch raus die
botschaft geht insbesondere auch an die
usa weil aus russischer perspektive die
usa in der vergangenheit schon mal
gesagt haben sie würden einen konflikt
nicht intervenieren jugoslawien oder
irak und hab es dann doch gemacht das
heißt aus russischer sicht ist dieser
hinweis haltet euch raus ein wichtiger
hinweis die man mit zum nuklearen
drohungen nochmal unter
unterstreichen kann die zweite idee
dahinter ist angst und sorge und
verwirrung in den westlichen
öffentlichkeiten zu schüren das sind man
die nukleare abrüstung nämlich durch
allein das sprechen über die waffe ist
schon eine waffe an sich denn es schürt
natürlich angst in den westlichen
öffentlichkeiten und die idee dahinter
ist dass dann wir die westlichen
öffentlichkeiten druck auf unsere
regierungen ausüben und sagen überlegt
euch mal die serie die ukraine
unterstützt brauchen wir wirklich die
schweren waffen um damit
wirklich unruhe und angst zu säen das
sind die beiden ideen hinter dem
nuklearen drohungen die haben wir
gesehen sowohl mit übungen als auch mit
diesen ankündigungen dass die waffe
scharf gestellt werden das muss man
verstehen ich glaube es gibt aber viele
gründe warum man das ernst nehmen muss
aber nicht in panik verfallen sollte
strohmeier dann müssen wir sofort mal
auf den brief kommen der geschrieben
worden ist von alice schwarzer die
terror und anderen intellektuellen das
war ja ein brief der den bundeskanzler
aufgefordert hat zu verhandlungen zu
drängen und die schweren waffen nicht in
die ukraine zu liefern aus angst vor
einer eskalation die vor allen dingen
aber auch mit der atomwaffe was zu tun
hatte ist das eine sinnvolle diskussion
oder ist dass alle diskussionen bei der
im kreml große begeisterung herrscht ich
glaube dass jeder debatte ob man schwere
waffen liefert oder nicht wie man diesen
krieg beenden kann ich glaube dass diese
debatten sinnvoll sind und dass sie
notwendig sind und das ist eine stärke
der demokratie ist dass wir diese
debatten offen führen können das ist in
anderen ländern etwa in russland nicht
möglich da darf man nicht mal über krieg
sprechen das läuft unter
spezialoperation was ich wichtig finde
ist den schritt zurück zu gehen und zu
überlegen wie man diese insbesondere die
nuklearen drohung einordnen sollte und
wenn man sich dann die russischen
drohungen ansieht kann man ein relativ
klares muster erkennen wer man der regel
den präsidenten der droht beispielsweise
mit konsequenzen die man noch nie
gesehen hat häufig kommt danach der
außenminister lavrov der das so ein
bisschen relativiert der beispielsweise
auch auf gemeinsame stellungnahme
verweist und sagt ein atomkrieg kann ich
gewonnen wären werden und dann kommt
häufig der regierungssprecher und sagt
wir wollen ja eigentlich auch keine
nukleare eskalation das heißt die
kommunikation ist nicht so klar wie sie
hier häufig wahrgenommen wird das muss
man sehr klar sagen wir müssen auch
anerkennen dass wir bislang eine drohung
auf der rhetorischen ebene haben die ist
sehr ernst zu nehmen es gibt aber ein
automatismus auf die militärische ebene
militärischer ebene hieße beispielsweise
dass die waffen verlegt werden dass die
alarmstufe erhöht werden das haben wir
bislang nicht gesehen und so hat es auch
klingt müssen wir uns auch überlegen
dass wir die kosten nutzen rechnung für
russland aussehen würde welchen nutzen
hätte russland von einem einsatz der
einst zivilisationsbruch wäre es gibt
keinen nuklearen einsatz seit 1945 und
was wären die kosten die entstehen
würden und da haben die usa sehr klar
gemacht dass ein der der einsatz von
atomwaffen für sie die rechnung völlig
verändern würde und sie wahrscheinlich
mit
einem oder man wahrscheinlich mit einem
amerikanischen kriegs anderen rechnen
müsste und dass sie natürlich vergelten
wurden ob sie nur klar vergelten wurden
wissen wir nicht aber sie würden
vergelten zwar setzte loch der mit die
mir wichtig sind
nicht nur die usa sehen das kritisch
auch andere staaten die bislang noch
eher zu russland tendieren wie china
oder indien sehen das als ein
zivilisationsbruch an und als einen
bruch der internationalen ordnung dass
auf einem nuklearen gleichgewicht
aufbaut das heißt die kosten wären enorm
hoch das heißt nicht dass es
ungefährlich wäre ich finde das
russische säbelrasseln zutiefst
unverantwortlich
aber wir müssen uns im klaren sein dass
dieses angst schüren genau das ziel der
russischen strategie ist die drohung mit
der bombe ist schon die waffe und wenn
wir uns damit zu sagen in panik
verfallen ist das de facto genau das was
putin erreichen wurde der
nobelpreisträger dimitrij muratow hat
gesagt das was da im augenblick in der
propaganda gespielt wird soll aber die
bevölkerung in russland daran gewöhnen
dass man so etwas machen könnte ist das
nicht tatsächlich eine gefahr dass wir
uns vielleicht auch im westen ein
bisschen daran gewöhnt das könnte
passieren und so eine nuklearwaffe über
der ostsee schürt eine enorme angst im
gesamten westen möglicherweise ja auch
in russland und wäre ja auch ein fanal
es wäre ein fanal aber nochmal ich
glaube wir müssen versuchen dass
rational zu analysieren es gab letzte
woche oder vor zehn tagen einen einen
test mit der russischen sammert rakete
russland hat sehr bewusst die usa vorher
über diesen test informiert was ich als
klares zeichen wertet dass sie keine
eskalation wollen und dass sie auch
keine missverständnisse wollen russland
hat die regeln der abschreckung bislang
verstanden oder respektiert kann man
sagen und sie haben sehr wohl darauf
geachtet dass sie eine eskalation mit
nato staaten vermieden haben deshalb
finde ich dieses etwas
geradezu
nicht herbeireden aber dieses als wäre
es normal dieser waffen zu nutzen ist
leichtfertig wir müssen das sehr ernst
nehmen aber es gibt keinen automatismus
und bislang haben diese regeln
funktioniert diese dieser der
abschreckungs regeln noch mal ich finde
das sehr sehr beunruhigend
wir sind auch in der eskalation weiter
als wir es vor dem krieg gewesen sind
aber es gibt das kann man auch sehen von
beiden seiten russland und den usa
bislang die bestrebungen das im
gleichgewicht zu halten sie sind ja nach
dieser partie jetzt auch alle ganz
großartige waffenexperten deswegen muss
ich trotzdem nach der saat rakete mal
fragen wir haben in den usa eine
sogenannte minutemen und wir haben in
den uhr in russland jetzt eine rakete
sammert die eigentlich alle ziele
erreichen kann mehr oder weniger auf der
welt und die unglaublich schnell ist und
bei der im russischen fernsehen gezeigt
wird wie schnell man in london und in
berlin und woanders ist was soll das ist
das reine angst erzeugung das ist
kommunikation nach innen also nach
russland rein um zu zeigen wie stark
russland ist auch für modernes ist dass
es sich auch nicht kleinkriegen lässt es
ist die abschreckung an die westliche
welt zu sagen dass ich dann haltet euch
raus
respektiert sozusagen russland in seinem
in diesem krieg in der ukraine
aber mir ist noch mal ein anderer punkt
wichtig nuklearwaffen sind keine
kriegsführung schwachen sie sind gedacht
als abschreckungs werfen sie sind
gedacht um den gegner zu signalisieren
wenn du mich angreifst werden die kosten
für einen angriff viel höher sein als
die gewinne die du dir erhofft ein
angriff lohnt sich nicht das sind also
kriegs verhinderungs waffen sie sind
nicht entwickelt worden um im
gefechtsfeld eingesetzt zu werden die
strategischen atomwaffen sind zu sagen
also wirklich kriegs verhinderungs bitte
taktischen atomwaffen da wird immer
wieder davon gesprochen die kann man so
einsetzen auch im kriegsgebiet dass
damit ein enormer effekt ausgelöst wird
er ist aber nicht gleichzeitig sozusagen
der beginn eines atomkriegs rund um die
welt
man kann jetzt den unterschied machen
zwischen kleineren und größeren
nuklearwaffen es bleibt eine
nuklearwaffe seit 1945 ist keine
nuklearwaffe mehr eingesetzt worden und
auch russland weiß dass diese
entscheidung ein fundamentaler bruch
wäre mit allen regeln und russland damit
zum paria in der internationalen
gemeinschaft würde auch mit blick auf
noch enge partner wie china und deswegen
glaube ich können wir diesen unterschied
machen zwischen den strategischen und
den taktischen und ja wenn man an der
taktische einsetzen würde wäre die
wirkung oder wären die auswirkungen
begrenzt es wäre aber immer noch der
einsatz einer nuklearwaffe das heißt es
würde auch in diesem falle eine reaktion
der usa oder auch der anderen staaten
hervorrufen weil es einfach ein
fundamentaler angriff auf die nukleare
ordnung auf das regelwerk und der faktor
auf die zivi torischen abkommen wäre
jetzt machen wir mal strich da drüben
treffer ich habe sie auch so verstanden
dass es wenig sinn macht wenn man diese
erklärungen die sie jetzt gott sei dank
noch einmal beigetragen haben ständig zu
wiederholen und ständig in der gegend
herum zu laufen und zu sagen meine güte
es könnte irgendwann ein atompilz um uns
herum entstehen machen den strich
drunter und ich würde gerne nochmal
darüber sprechen was wir für eine
gesellschaftliche diskussion im
augenblick haben haben wir nicht nur
diesen einen brief der den bundeskanzler
auffordert keine schweren waffen zu
liefern sondern es gibt ja auch einen
sozusagen gegen brief von marieluise
beck die sich seit sehr langer zeit mit
osteuropa und mit russland beschäftigt
und gerhart baum die sagen nein wir
müssen das gegenteil tun wir müssen
diese schweren waffen liefern wir müssen
der ukraine helfen noch mal die frage
spielt die diskussion in der
gesellschaft die ja nicht nur in
deutschland stattfindet putin in die
hände
ich glaube in die hände spielen ist ein
großes wort was wir gesehen haben
beispielsweise ist dass diese debatte
die wir in der deutschen öffentlichkeit
über die atomare bedrohung hatten
offensichtlich sich so ausgewirkt hat
dass die unterstützung für militärische
unterstützung für die ukraine etwas
runtergegangen ist und das fand ich
schon bemerkenswert man kann jetzt ist
immer schwer die qualität herzustellen
ob es deswegen war aber wenn man sich
die umfragen ansieht entsteht der
eindruck dass aufgrund der der der der
sorge einer atomaren eskalation auch so
ein bisschen die unterstützung für die
ukraine runter gegangen ist und das
finde ich
das finde ich schwierig weil es halt
einen ein ausschnitt der debatte ist
wenn wir uns überlegen was diese
waffenlieferungen für die ukraine
bewirken sollen und ich habe die
waffenlieferung ist nur ein teil es gibt
der faktor um die gesamte unterstützung
der kreml finanziellen mit waffen und
die wirtschaftssanktionen um russland zu
schwächen dann geht es darum die ukraine
in ihrem überlebensrate in ihrem
selbstverteidigungsrecht zu unterstützen
es geht nicht darum die ukraine für
einen angriffskrieg zu befähigen sondern
es geht darum dass sie den dem
vernichtungskrieg russland widerstehen
kann und im allerbesten fall momentan
noch relativ schwer vorstellbar die von
russland seit dem 24 seit kriegsbeginn
eroberten gebiete zurückzuerobern
das ist das ziel das ist einmal zu sagen
die ukraine zu befähigen ihr territorium
zurückzuerobern das geht aber auch darum
sie in eine gute verhandlungsposition zu
bringen selbst der russische
aussenminister sabrow sagt die
militärischen gegebenheiten entscheiden
über den über das danach das heißt so
wie der krieg endet das entscheidet über
den frieden das heißt es geht darum die
ukraine zu befähigen sich zu verteidigen
eine gute ausgangsposition für die
friedensverhandlungen zu haben es geht
aber auch darum weiteres leid zu
verhindern wir haben gesehen was unter
russischer besatzung in mario pohl oder
in butter passiert das heißt die in die
aufgabe weiteres leid noch größeres leid
zu verhindern ist eine ganz zentrale
aufgabe dabei aber das passt dass das
passt ja zusammen also das was wir jetzt
zb von pucher gesehen und gehört haben
ist ja auch angst erzeugung ist angst
einer der zentralen faktoren in der
russischen kriegsführung
also russland versucht mit der
kriegsführung diaz hat das überhaupt
nicht auf völkerrecht wert legt dass
keine rücksicht auf zivilisten versucht
es angst zu schüren es versucht angst so
schön in der zivilbevölkerung
durch diese vernichtung durch die
kriegsverbrechen durch die durch die
plünderung durch die vergewaltigungen
und das versucht auch die moral der
streitkräfte damit zu unterminieren es
funktioniert offensichtlich nicht denn
wir sehen dass das diese dieses extrem
brutale und rücksichtslose vorgehen auch
durch die zerstörung von krankenhäusern
und ähnlich ist das ist nicht dazu
geführt hat dass die moral der
streitkräfte oder der bevölkerung in der
ukraine runtergegangen sind im gegenteil
es hat er dazu geführt dass sie das der
verteidigungs oder noch stärker geworden
ist aber ja es scheint eine einen ansatz
einer russischen strategie zu sein jetzt
gibt es leute die im augenblick sagen es
gibt keinen besseren zeitpunkt
die russische armee hat nicht die ziele
erreicht die sie erreichen wollte die
ukrainische armee ist stärker als sie
eingeschätzt wurde
verhandlungen zu beginnen
handlung setzen voraus dass auf beiden
seiten interesse an verhandlungen
besteht und wenn ich mir die bisherigen
verhandlungsverlauf ansehe
hat besteht aus roussel von russischer
seite kein ehrliches interesse diesen
konflikt zu beenden wir können sogar
noch schritt zurückgehen kann sagen vor
ausbruch des krieges gab es enorm viele
bemühungen auch von seiten des
bundeskanzlers von makro von fast allen
westlichen staatsführer eine
verhandlungslösung zu bekommen es gab
damals die idee man könnte die mindest
verhandlungen noch einmal aufnehmen und
wir müssen uns ehrlich machen daran
erkennen dass russland die möglichkeiten
diesen krieg nicht ausbrechen zu lassen
ich wahrgenommen hat und die
möglichkeiten jetzt diesen krieg
anzuhalten auch nicht wahrgenommen hat
es gab von ukrainischer seite relativ
weit reichende
verhandlungsangebote und sie lenski
hatte angeboten dass die ukraine neutral
wird dass wir auf einen nato beitritt
verzichtet es gab bislang von russischer
seite kein interesse darauf einzugehen
vermutlich weil sie glauben dass sie
ihre ziele militärisch noch erreichen
können was ist das ziel putins er hat
drei ziele jetzt schon nicht erreicht er
hat die ukrainische bevölkerung nicht
für die russische sache
sozusagen motivieren können im gegenteil
das wird wahrscheinlich generationen ein
traum bleiben die russen waren hier und
haben unsere landsleute getötet er hat
militärisch nicht die erfolge erreicht
die er erreichen wollte in kurzer zeit
und letztendlich hat er auch nicht
vermitteln können dass das tatsächlich
ein in anführungsstrichen
richtiger krieg ist
was ist sein ziel was macht er jetzt
eigentlich im kreml und mit was für
zielen muss er sich jetzt sozusagen
auseinandersetzen also was sein ziel ist
das weiß ja im endeffekt nur ganz
alleine wir können uns als außenstehende
versuchen dem an zu lernen indem wir uns
seine reden angucken um seine artikel
angucken und seine seine statements
angucken und die von
regierungsmitgliedern
unterscheiden sich so ein paar ideen
heraus zu kristallisieren das eine ist
dass er der ukraine die staatlichkeit
abspricht die eigene identität ab
spricht und sagt es gibt eigentlich
keine ukraine sie hat eigentlich keinen
kein recht als eigener souveräner staat
zu existieren sie gehört eigentlich zu
russland das konnte man in publikationen
von putin sehen das hat sich auch in den
öffentlichen meinung in den öffentlichen
statements von regierungsvertretern
immer wieder gesehen wenn man sich jetzt
diesen krieg ansieht scheint es viele
gegeben zu haben einmal den
systemwechsel eliten wechsel also die
regierung der faktor abzusetzen und
entweder russlandfreundlich oder eine
andere marionettenregierung einzusetzen
die regierung zu wechseln die die eliten
auszuwechseln also die pro westlichen
eliten auszuwechseln dann die
infrastruktur so zu reduzieren gerade
die militärisch und dass die ukraine
militärisch selbst nicht mehr
handlungsfähig wäre und damit de facto
die ukraine als eigenständigen
souveränen staat der sich nach westen
orientiert abzuschaffen und in eine art
vasallenstaat zu verwandeln die
ursprüngliche idee offenbar war das das
mit einer relativ schnellen
militärischen aktion innerhalb von ein
paar tagen klappt hat nicht funktioniert
wie kam es zu dieser fehleinschätzung
wir verstehen doch nicht dass dort
militärs sitzen das strategen dort
sitzen dass man solche dinge sogar
durchgespielt haben dürfte und man hat
sich so komplett verschätzt es lag zu
verschiedenen verschiedenen gründen ab 1
und war das dass es auf falschen
vorannahmen aufbaute also auf falschen
informationen am falschen verständnis
über die ukrainische bevölkerung
gesellschaft das heißt dass russland
oder die entscheidungsträger in russland
nicht wahrgenommen haben wie tief sich
die ukrainische bevölkerung den letzten
jahren verändert hat und wie sehr sie
eine eigene ukrainische identität und
das bestreben hatte sich eher in die
westliche richtung eu nato zu entwickeln
mit einer freien gesellschaft mit einer
freien öffentlichkeit dass das in
russland in derart nicht wahrgenommen
worden ist und sie tatsächlich glaubten
das wäre eine sie will und sie würden
damit offenen armen empfangen also
falsche vorannahmen auch falsche vorname
mit blick auf die einsatzfähigkeit des
russischen militärs das deutliche
schwächen an den tag gelegt in der
kommandokette in der logistik in der
moral der truppen das heißt in vielen
punkten falsche vorannahmen falsche
vorname auch mit blick auf die stärke
der ukrainischen armee die sich deutlich
einsatzfähiger gezeigt hat als groß
anders erwartet hat und der reaktion des
westens russland wird nicht erwartet
haben dass die westlichen staaten so
geschlossen reagieren würden und dann
auch so geschlossen und entschlossen mit
blick auf die sanktion und die
militärische unterstützung angehen
würden das heißt in jeglicher hinsicht
viele falsche vorname der hat ja das
gegenteil von dem erreicht was er wollte
er hat den westen nicht
auseinanderdividieren können der hat
nicht in kurzer zahlt die ukraine
übernehmen können und er hat nicht
innenpolitisch die situation gestärkt
welche situation findet denn putin im
augenblick vor er sieht dass die ukraine
die bevölkerung und die regierung
deutlich besser wieder steht und
er sieht dass die westlichen staaten
bereit sind die ukraine in einem maximum
zu unterstützen
wirtschaftlich finanziell und
militärisch
und ich denke dass er diese
unterstützung wirklich unterschätzt hat
die große frage ist jetzt inwieweit die
konzentration auf den don was also am
anfang gab es in vier große militärische
angriffspunkte kiew der süden und am
bass und jetzt konzentriert sich
russland auf den don bass und die
landbrücke vom don was rüber zu grämen
die frage ist ist es ein wirklicher
wechsel das gesamte gesagt uns
interessiert muss noch der donners und
die landbrücke oder ob es nur eine
vorübergehende an zug ist und sobald es
militärisch wieder besser läuft russland
versuchen wird die kriegshandlungen
wieder auszuweiten
leider spricht vieles für die zweite
variante also eine vorübergehende
konzentration und sobald es geht wieder
auszuweiten wenn man sich die
öffentlichen äußerungen von
regierungsvertretern und von militärs
anguckt die reden auch von der bedrohung
in transnistrien die reden immer noch
dass die ukraine and ukraine siert
werden sollte so das heißt dass sie ihre
eigene identität aufgeben sollte die
reden immer noch von entnazifizierung in
russland wird der krieg legitimiert
damit dass die ukraine eigentlich ein
verzicht faschistischer und nazi staat
wäre und das müsste man das müsste man
reinigen das heißt in den öffentlichen
äußerungen der russischen
regierungsvertreter ist das narrativ
eigentlich immer noch da dass die
ukraine kein status dass sie endlich
saniert werden müsste und dass sie
eigentlich vorgenommen werden bei den
bildern die wir jetzt im augenblick
sehen kann man sich ja eine
kurzfristige wiederaufbauleistung gar
nicht vorstellen das sind ja komplett
zerstörte städte das heißt aber auch
dass letztendlich russland selbst wenn
es die ukraine in teilen oder ganz
erobern könnte ein völlig desolaten
start vor findet auch desolate in der
infrastruktur ist der cyberwar eine
sache die zurückgehalten worden ist oder
findet er im augenblick statt da hört
man sehr wenig zu es gibt relativ viele
cyberangriffe in die gab's 2014 also wir
müssen uns auch mal daran zurück
erinnern dass seit der alexander grimm
und dem krieg in uns das 2014 hersteller
keinen frieden sondern es herrscht ein
permanenter konflikt wo russland die
ukraine permanent unter druck gesetzt
hat mit cyber angriffen mit fake news
mit wirtschaftlichen druck mit kleineren
militärischen zwischenfällen an der
kontakt linie das und diese dimensionen
die sehen wir jetzt auch noch
aber mir ist noch ein anderer punkt
wichtiger nicht nur ist das land
zerstört man kann auch sagen selbst wenn
russland den krieg gewinnt kann es den
kriegen nicht gewinnen weil es einen in
einem land steht was die russische
besatzung zutiefst ablehnt das heißt es
ist ja keine befriedung die russische
besatzung sondern es hat eine
bevölkerung
gegen sich
wir haben bestrebungen finnlands und
schwedens die sehr konkret sind der nato
beizutreten ist das ein schritt der die
situation noch immer weiter eskaliert
aus sicht der russen ich glaube man
sollte die frage anders stellen und
sollte fragen haben sind nicht finnland
und schweden als souveräne staaten haben
sie nicht das recht zu sagen wir wollen
gerne art und mitglied werden wir haben
uns mal in europa auf grundsätze
geeinigt zusammen mit der sowjetunion
helsinki schlussakte in den 70ern danach
mit der russischen föderation charta von
paris danach auch noch der nato russland
schlussakte von uns grund akte pardon
von 197 wo russland und die westlichen
staaten sich auf prinzipien geeinigt
haben auf die sie alle wichtig da morgen
romario werden unsere grundlagen geht ja
punkten gar nicht betreiben das
interessiert hat sie abgeräumt das heißt
aber nicht dass wir sie auch abräumen
sollten denn de facto was die ukraine
macht die ukraine sagt ich möchte als
freier souveräner staat entscheiden wo
ich in welchem bündnis ich mitglied
werde und wie ich mich selber
entwicklung möchte ich ein liberaler
freistaat seien oder nicht aus
russischer perspektive
hat die ukraine kein recht dazu wir
haben eben darüber gesprochen was die
ziele putins in der ukraine sind meines
erachtens verwandlung in einen ballsaal
im staat aber das geht de facto über die
ukraine hinaus denn die vorstellung die
dahinter steht ist ja dass russland also
größerer start bei seinem nachbarn einem
kleineren staaten wörtchen mitzureden
hat dass größere städte in größere
staaten mehr rechte haben als kleinere
staaten und damit kommen wir de facto
zurück zu einem großmächte konzert und
europa und die groß und das sagen haben
und die kleine mal pech gehabt wenn sie
dazwischen sind das die eigentliche idee
vielleicht von putin auch gewesen der ja
die historie in seiner sehr eigenartigen
form interpretiert im sinne von lass uns
nur noch unter den großen sozusagen die
welt miteinander aufteilen das steht
dahinter also hinter dem anspruch ich
wenn die ukraine in den westen will muss
ich mich fragen war einfach formuliert
dahinter steht die idee von einer völlig
anderen interaktionen von staaten in
europa nämlich nicht mehr so wie wir es
verstehen weil es auch in der
europäischen union wo eine einer
abstimmung bald island stimme genau so
viel gewicht wie deutschlands sondern
tatsächlich die rückkehr zu den großen
mächte konzert und woody kleineren
weniger zu sagen haben und wo ist das
recht auf freie bildnis wahl nicht mehr
gibt oder wenn man das wie in diesem
krieg noch weiter drehen wo man sagt das
gilt das rechte stärkeren und ich kann
mit militär meiner interessen
durchsetzen ich kann krieg führen und
kann damit meine interessen durchsetzen
das widerspricht fundamental
der vorstellung die wir von einer
sicherheits ordnung in europa haben oder
einem zusammenleben von staaten haben
jetzt könnte es ja staaten geben die
durchaus in einer mehr oder weniger
neutralen position sind oder sich gut
vorstellen dass man sich aus diesem
konflikt ganz raus hält die aber
gleichzeitig sagen die weltordnung ganz
zertrümmern zu lassen das wollen wir nun
auch nicht gestatten ich spreche
natürlich unter anderem china an halten
sie die chance immer noch für groß dass
sich china ab einem gewissen punkt der
eskalation einmischt und putin bremst
das ist unheimlich schwer vorherzusagen
der chinesische präsident ist
wahrscheinlich der einzige der wirklich
einfluss auf putin hat und er hat sich
bislang
zumindest so wie wir es von außen
wahrnehmen entschieden diesen einfluss
noch nicht zu nutzen
wann das kippt
ist unheimlich schwer vorherzusagen aus
chinesischer sicht ist es auch so dass
sie natürlich ihr verhältnis zu den
europäern nicht aufs spiel setzen wollen
und nicht fundamental verschlechtern
würden und das wäre natürlich die folge
wenn sie china ganz offensichtlich und
ganz klar auf die russische seite
stellen würde ich glaube was was für
russland momentan wichtig sind sind
starten die ihnen helfen die sanktionen
zu umgehen
und da kann eine rolle spiele und andere
staaten rolle spielen aber wann sich
china
klarer positioniert das ist sehr schwer
vorherzusagen
die sanktionen greifen wir haben jetzt
diskussion um weitere embargo formen
also etwa beim öl wie stark ist der
druck den wir dadurch auslösen können
oder umgekehrt gefragt wie stark
schädigen wir dadurch die wirtschaft in
russland was dann letztendlich auch eine
frage der reaktionen in russland ist die
sanktionen wirken sie wirken aber in
ihrer vollen also sie wirken jetzt schon
aber die volle kraft entfalten sie über
einen längeren zeitraum und damit haben
wir so ein problem zwischen der krieg
entscheidet sich jetzt in diesem
augenblick das merken wir ja aber die
schwächung die die sanktionen
hervorrufen wirken wahrscheinlich erst
später und diese diese verschiedenen
zeitachsen sind zumindest für die
aktuellen kriegs entwicklungen schwierig
weil die mutter sanktionen wirken ja
aber sie wirken sich jetzt direkt aber
heißt das denn je länger der krieg
dauert so schrecklich das ist umso
wahrscheinlicher ist dass der
wirtschaftliche schaden für russland so
groß ist dass man möglicherweise sogar
einlenken muss
das wird sich zeigen also natürlich ist
das szenario eines russlands was
zusammenbricht was wirtschaftlich und
politisch zusammenbricht ein sehr
beunruhigendes so wie es bislang
aussieht ist das nicht das nächste
szenario und wann beispielsweise kritik
in dem andere in den engeren zirkel um
putin kommt wann es dazu veränderung
kommt das ist unheimlich schwer zu sagen
wenn wir darauf gucken wie der krieg
beendet werden kann ist das ein szenario
das immer wieder auf den tisch kommt man
sagt in der regel der krieg kann beendet
werden wenn einer von den beiden
parteien gewinnt das sind momentan nicht
so aus und weiter variante ist dass man
eine sonne einem zermürbung und
abnutzungskrieg kommt darauf scheinen
wir momentan hinauszulaufen und die
dritte variante ist die person wild card
szenario eine überraschung szenario oder
politischer wechsel szenario das heißt
wenn einer der beiden ländern russland
oder der ukraine ist zu einem
politischen wechsel kommen würde und
sich damit auch die rolle des krieges
verändert wenn es wirklich zu einem
politischen wechsel in russland kommen
sollte dann ist vielleicht der krieg
nicht mehr ganz so wichtig weil sie mit
ihren machtkämpfen beschäftigt sind und
dann wäre es möglich dass russland
ernsthaftes interesse an verhandlungen
hat und möglicherweise auf die land
gewinne verzichtet das ist am so gehört
es ganz viel möglicherweise drin aber
das wäre eine variante wie
dieser krieg zu einem ende kommen könnte
der neunte mai ist ein ganz ganz
besonderer tag für russland
was kann putin am neunten mal vorweisen
der neubau interessanterweise ist erst
in den letzten jahren unter putin so
hoch stilisiert worden und mit diesen
riesengroßen militärparaden unterlegt
worden in der vergangenheit war dass er
so ein tag zum nachdenken und auch der
trauer
und dieses sehr bombastisch
nationalistische ist erst in den letzten
jahrzehnten eigentlich gekommen
putin kann verschiedene sachen vorweisen
wenn er den militärischen erfolg in dem
maße nicht vorweisen kann kann er was
vorweisen aber nicht so groß wie
ursprünglich gedacht kann er anhand von
anderen sachen versuchung erfolge
vorzuweisen beispielsweise die idee dass
in einigen städten wie mario pohl oder
personen der rubel als zahlungsmittel
eingeführt worden ist oder dass
referenten über sogenannte volksrepublik
stattfinden was ja alles zeichen nicht
nur dass erfolge sind sondern fast noch
bedrohlicher zeichen von wir sind hier
um zu bleiben also eine langfristige
veränderung und zugehörigkeit zu
verändern das heißt je nachdem wie es
gefällt wird kann er erfolge vorweisen
er kann es aber auch versuchen um das
narrativ zu verändern wenn man sich
jetzt die russische um berichterstattung
anguckt merkt man so eine kleine
veränderung hin dass es immer mehr einen
krieg auch als krieg gegen die nato
krieg gegen den westen gefeiert wird
nicht mehr nur gegen die sogenannten
faschisten in der ukraine ist natürlich
hanebüchen ist sondern auch gegen den
westen und dass dieser neunte mai
nochmal als als kristallisationspunkt
genutzt wird um die bevölkerung
einzustellen auf unterstützungen
möglicherweise auch auf mehr leiden
möglicherweise auch auf mehrkosten
was werden wir denn in ein paar jahren
kindern erklären wie es dazu gekommen
es gab einen großen nachbarn
der seinen kleineren nachbarn
überfallen hat und versucht hat mit dem
recht des stärkeren
seine interessen durchzudrücken
und die frage ist wie sich der kleinere
nachbar dagegen gewehrt hat und er hat
sich besser gewährt als wir gedacht
haben und er hat verstärkung von seinen
freunden bekommen
und das ist glaube ich ein sehr
interessantes element in dieser
aktuellen debatte
die westlichen staaten merken dass ihre
unterstützung militärisch finanziell und
durch die sanktionen einen unterschied
macht das die ukraine so lange
widerstanden hat liegt natürlich zuerst
an der ukraine es liegt aber auch daran
dass die westlichen staaten ich
entschlossen haben durch die
waffenlieferung oder mit der
finanziellen stützung der altenhilfe und
den sanktionen die ausgangslage zu
verändern und das ist eine interessante
frage wenn man immer fragt wie geht es
denn jetzt weiter wir wissen es nicht
erstens und zweitens es liegt auch daran
wie wir uns weiter vorhanden
war ja ganz vielen dank dass sie bei mir
war dankeschön
[Musik]